you think people would be as attracted
tor if they knew that her name
translates as r annette fish
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review and we are up
to the girl in the fireplace now this
one was an interesting one for me to go
back and revisit because in an odd way I
tend to forget about it not that I ever
thought it was a bad episode I actually
always quite liked it but whenever I
would tend to think of my favorite
episodes or even my favorite Moffat
written episodes other you know
commenters and whatnot would always like
they'd always be sure to bring this up
and I would forget to bring it up so I
really wanted to go back and try and
figure out if I could either like figure
out why it kind of never left as much of
an impression as I would have thought or
you know if that just you know if I just
if it sinks in better I just absorb it
better this time I'm not sure either one
has happened yeah so I I came away first
let me say if you loved this episode
awesome like I can I can look at it and
I can go I can see all the things that
I'm like that's good that's good that's
great that's awesome that's well paced
and yet somehow it doesn't connect quite
right and I still don't know why it's
honestly this happens to me at a number
of points in Doctor Who like sometimes
something will I will understand why
it's emotionally affecting why it is
paying off well but it still didn't
actually hit that note I only understand
on an intellectual level like in the
case of this episode that it's poignant
and sad I'm not saying that it isn't but
I'm saying for whatever reason the
construction that should be bringing
those emotions out of me isn't quite
doing it but does since I don't know I
still don't know why that is let's focus
on some of the good stuff so obviously
Tennant is real
I mean he he got this roll right off but
he's really settling in at this point
kind of you know was bouncing around and
his sense of adventure which was one of
the things that I do like about his his
doctor I'm I I'm trying to be careful to
not be overly sliding off of Tennant cuz
I feel like I have been in the last you
know year or so just because he's kind
of been dropping in my estimation
relative to other doctors but I do like
that sort of well I love that you know
something like he you know says you know
monsters have nightmares too and the
young res is what do they have
nightmares about me and you know this
this sort of Tallyho thing going on and
I quite like that element of him when
it's at play and it is at play here
I actually I I wish
Mickey had travelled in the TARDIS for
longer than he did because I actually
quite like the dynamic of ROS kind of
having fun with him there and you know
him you'll get you know starting to
appreciate what she sees in all this but
the doctor like basically forgetting
that he's around I kind of oddly liked
that dynamic and I kind of wish we had
it for a longer than we did we've got
the clockwork robots which I met I again
I never found them scary even now I
didn't find them scary I think it's a
really cool conceit the whole idea of
hey that clocks broken so what's ticking
like that's cool I do like that and I
mean the once the masks are off the look
of them is pretty neat too and I like
the the rationale behind what they're
doing because it is it is the kind of
thing that like makes sense if you think
about well these are machines that are
operating within the parameters that
they've been given and within those
parameters what they're doing makes
sense and at this point there's no one
left to explain to them why this doesn't
work what it is they're trying to do
they're just going about it in the best
way that they can I kind of like that
you know they've just they've just gone
too far down this logic hole to to come
to this conclusion that is insane but
they're gonna do it and I I kind of
enjoy how that pans out and then the
final reveal for the name of the ship
makes that all play very well Madame de
Pompadour herself is very well performed
I think I feel like in some ways the
actress was hampered by the overly
formal language not always I think when
she is you know having her flirtier
moments with the doctor it works really
well you know how well informally she
speaks with him it kind of it it works
well in the in the interplay between
them however when she is in situations
that are a little bit more dire the fact
that she's still speaking in this
slightly stilted overly formal way of
speaking it kind of pulls me out of it a
little bit and I feel like in some ways
having to do that at moments where you
know in theory she should be slightly
more commanded by emotion then one would
expect from someone who's still speaking
like that I feel like that actually kind
of kneecapped her performance a little
bit in some moments not again not always
and I think she does about as well as
you could do with the part III just that
like that's one of the few things that I
kind of glommed on to this time I'm like
maybe that's what's sort of throwing it
off a little bit for me
I love the horse where's the horse has
stuck around why don't I get more of the
horse but I also structurally really
like it I I it's I mean it's it gets
come back and I would argue refined when
we get to Amy Pond eventually but I like
this idea of someone encountering the
doctor across their life like this and
it's interesting to get it from the
doctor's perspective where this person
just keeps getting a little bit older
every time and there is a sadness to it
especially because you know the doctor
leaves for what is supposed to be
20 seconds and he comes back and he's
too late and again I do get why that sad
it just doesn't actually twist at the
heartstrings at me quite properly but
fur for what is planned what is laid out
and what is executed now it's good stuff
it's just for whatever reason this one
doesn't have for me and possibly only
for me doesn't have the emotional
resonance that it's trying for which is
probably why I tend to forget about it
because what it's trying to do I'm not
gonna say it fails at but it didn't
succeed it with me which means that I
kind of drifts off in my mind as
something that you know didn't quite
come together the way it was meant to I
don't know if I've articulated any of
this very well at all cuz like I said I
barely understand it like I feel like I
should like this episode a lot more than
I do
and I do like it I don't dislike it but
I cannot ignore the fact that I'm
obviously supposed to have a stronger
emotional reaction to it than I do and I
know a ton of other fans of this show do
have a much stronger emotional reaction
to it than I do um and like really at
this point you need to real I'm a huge
softie at this point ever since I had a
kid like the things that will set me off
and you know get me to choke up it does
not take much when it hits me right for
whatever reason this quite this doesn't
quite do it but the performances are
good you know the design on the on the
clockwork robots is good the the
structure is cool I like the conceit I
like the dynamic between Renetta and the
doctor and and that sort of flirtation
between them I like all of it I just
don't love any of it I guess that's
where I land ultimately
the girl on the fireplace maybe chalk
this under the pile of unpopular
opinions I should keep track of those
cuz like every now and then people ask
me what are your unpopular Doctor Who
opinions and I actually kind of don't
know because I don't like keep my finger
on the pulse of what is or isn't
accepted fandom wisdom very carefully so
like there are things that I think and I
go wait do other people actually feel
that way or if I or do I have the
unpopular opinion I don't know actually
I should try and figure that out one of
these days because I feel bad not
knowing an answer to that question in
any case whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it what is something you can
do because there's buttons and there's
links including one to the patreon if
you feel like supporting me that way
there's also a whole bunch of other
stuff down there as well P o box other
links etc check them out in the
description if you want to if you don't
want it that's okay because at the end
of the day folks you're the council I
just run the matings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]